a massive and coordinated effort to
steal this election electoral fraud that
would be perpetrated through electronic
voting they used the machines to trash
large batches
like these are at the center of a 1.6
billion dollar defamation case against
Fox News Dominion voting systems sued
the broadcaster in 2021 over alleged
defamatory on-air comments that tied the
company's voting machines to false
claims of election fraud in 2020. this
case really examines that line between
what is journalism and what should be
protected and what shouldn't be from
internal text messages to high-profile
depositions here's what you need to know
about the case
during the 2020 presidential election
voting machine maker Dominion had
contracts in 28 States and after former
president Donald Trump lost Fox had his
associates on broadcasts Sydney Powell
and Rudy Giuliani claiming that Dominion
rigged the election in favor of
President Joe Biden federal and state
officials have said there is no evidence
that any voting system deleted or
changed votes during the 2020 election
the company argues that by airing those
claims Fox News gave them prominence
even though they were false fox says
that it was reporting on newsworthy
claims from a sitting president and his
associates that other media Outlets also
covered Dominion's main argument is that
Fox News knowingly broadcast false
claims about its machines because it had
a financial incentive to do so fox has
denied that allegation many Executives
in a lot of these email Communications
were expressing a lot of angst about
losing viewership so Dominion alleges
that fox leaned into the false claims to
keep its viewers in released court
filings minion says that internal
Communications among Fox hosts and staff
prove that fox knew the claims were
false like a text message from Tucker
Carlson to his producer which said
Sydney Powell is lying and another one
he sent to Laura Ingram that said it's
unbelievably offensive to me our viewers
are good people and they believe it and
in her deposition Fox hosts Maria
Bartiromo called an email regarding the
election fraud claims from Powell kooky
and unreliable but on her show a day
after receiving the email Sydney we
talked about the Dominion software I
know that there were voting
irregularities tell me about that
that's to put it mildly the computer
glitches could not and should not have
happened in at all those that is where
the fraud took place where they were
flipping votes in the computer system or
adding votes that did not exist all of
these domain will use to say fox had a
disregard for the facts of the case fox
says that it's on air hosts didn't make
the Dominion election fraud claims
themselves Dominion also released a
deposition from Fox Corporation chairman
Rupert Murdoch who also owns News Corp
the parent company of the Wall Street
Journal he did acknowledge that some of
the broadcasts did endorse claims of a
false election as opposed to Simply
reporting on them and he acknowledged
that he could have stopped it from
happening fox says that these quotes
were cherry-picked from the deposition
but those statements on their own
dominion will try to use to show that
Executives like Rupert Murdoch had
control over these decisions that were
made on air the judge said prior to the
trial that he would require Murdoch and
other Fox Corp Executives to testify if
Dominion subpoenaed them in a statement
fox said demanding Witnesses who had
nothing to do with the challenged
broadcasts is just the latest example of
their political crusade in search of a
financial windfall FOX also says the
lawsuit is an attack on press Freedom
the 1964 Supreme Court case New York
Times versus Sullivan says that
plaintiffs suing for defamation must be
able to prove that the publisher had
actual malice which means that you knew
that the information was wrong or you
had a reckless disregard for the truth
in publishing it it's a historically
High bar to meet and fox says that
Dominion's evidence doesn't clear it
they say that some of the statements
that have been highlighted text messages
expressing doubt or simply cherry-picked
they believe that the host did Express
in some extent expressed enough
skepticism on air like here when Tucker
Carlson said he invited Powell to back
up her claims with evidence but she
never sent us any evidence despite a lot
of requests polite requests not a page
Dominion says that the emails texts and
deposition testimony speak for
themselves in late March judge Eric
Davis ruled the case should go to a jury
trial the judge also rejected Fox's
arguments that they should be protected
by the First Amendment and that they
could have a shield for reporting
allegations neutrally fox says that the
newsworthiness of the statements at
issue are clear and indisputable the
judge also said that Dominion had proved
that claims the company had rigged the
election for Joe Biden were false days
before the trial was set to begin judge
Davis said he was likely to investigate
whether Fox News improperly withhelding
information during litigation he also
said Fox might face sanctions Fox news
said it didn't improperly withhold
information from dominion and produced
additional materials when it became
aware of them
so the trial will likely focus on
whether Dominion can prove Fox acted
with actual malice and if it suffered
Financial damages as a result this trial
is a rare example of a defamation case
making it all the way to trial and it's
particularly important because Fox News
is a huge name in media and they have a
lot of influence and so it'll be in some
ways a test of this very difficult
standard of defamation
[Music]